l'artisanat ont fait quelque chose de
ses mains intéressant
c'est le métier que je suis meilleur
environnement levier tous fermés non la
partie des structures qui ne fonctionne
pas forcément comme
on voudrait
bon sens
[Musique]
pour les économistes le mot travail est
avant tout utilisé pour parler d'emploi
c'est à dire de l'exercice d'une
activité rémunérée
cette activité est donc ce qui permet
d'obtenir un salaire
ce dernier ayant vocation à être dépensé
pour se nourrir se loger ou acheter un
album de francis lalanne
selon cette logique économique ne pas
tarder travail est un drame s'est dit
tel quel dans un dictionnaire
d'économies le chômeur relégué en dehors
du monde travail perd la capacité de
subvenir à ses besoins
cette idée de la valeur travail est déjà
présente dans la bible dans la bouche de
l'apôtre paul
c'est quelqu'un ne veut pas travailler
qu'ils ne mangent pas non plus c'est une
formule choc qui interprété
littéralement a eu beaucoup de succès on
retrouve d'ailleurs par la suite cette
idée chez toutes sortes de penseurs et
pas que chez les néo libéraux
elle est présente dénoncé par nietzsche
chez la bourgeoisie du 19e siècle et on
la trouve aussi dans le manifeste du
parti communiste au xxème siècle servira
autant à reagan et thatcher et l'union
soviétique
au delà des époques des clivages
politiques cette formule résume à elle
seule notre rapport au travail
inséparable de la condition humaine
[Musique]
cette idée que celui qui ne travaille
pas n'est pas légitime pour obtenir de
quoi vivre est toujours présente dans
notre société
elles mêmes portées par des gens parfois
hostile à la tradition religieuse
parfois défenseur des pauvres car il
semble porter en elle l'équité ceux qui
sont visés sont ceux qui ne veulent même
pas travailler
faisant ainsi de l'oisiveté est la mère
de tous les maux et menaçant du même
coup l'equilibre de la société pourtant
est-ce bien réaliste
la france est un pays qui se nourrit et
même exporte des denrées alimentaires
avec seulement 1 5 % d'agriculteurs dans
la population
l'idée qu'il faut travailler pour se
nourrir n'a donc matériellement pas lieu
d'être
une écrasante majorité d'entre nous
mangeons donc le travail de cette petite
minorité dans notre société le travail
est donc devenu un effort qu'il faut
réaliser pas parce qu'il est nécessaire
à la société est plutôt parce qu'il est
juste que chacun fasse sa part bien sûr
cet argument de la nourriture à une
limite que vous avez certainement déjà
entrevue d'ailleurs se nourrir c'est
bien mais ça ne suffit pas il faut des
vêtements des maisons des meubles et si
on ajoute aux agriculteurs les médecins
les maçons les profs des artisans et
cetera et cetera
ça finit par faire du monde nous avons
donc besoin du travail des autres pour
vivre convenablement
c'est un principe élémentaire de
l'économie qu'on appelle la division du
travail
théorisée par adam smith il y as presque
250 ans chaque individu se concentre sur
une activité il se spécialise ce qui lui
permet d'être plus efficace et plus il
ya d'individus plus il est possible de
se spécialiser
comme dans un hôpital s'il n'y a qu'un
médecin il devra être généraliste
s'ils sont dix on pourra alors trouver
un chirurgien un ophtalmo un dermato etc
etc
finalement ce qui cause notre dépendance
au travail des autres c'est notre
incapacité à faire ce qu'ils font nous
avons beaucoup de besoins ou envies se
loger se vêtir se soigner se divertir de
tas de manières différentes
mais très peu de moyens
si on faisait la liste des produits des
outils les machines que nous utilisons
quotidiennement
combien serez tous en mesure de
fabriquer qu il faut se rendre à
l'évidence ne savons pas faire grand
chose
toutefois il ya une société où c'est
exactement contraire on y trouve des
personnes qui ont peu de besoin mais
beaucoup de moyens chaque individu c'est
presque tout faire je veux parler des
chasseurs cueilleurs dans les sociétés
de chasseurs cueilleurs entendait les
gens qui dépendent des ressources
sauvage pour leur subsistance
il est matériellement possible de se
débrouiller tout seul ou presque chaque
individu s'est fabriqué un arc taille
des silex construire un abri allumé un
feu ou cueillir les bonnes plantes à la
bonne saison
ce savoir est d'ailleurs ce qui a permis
à vichy le dernier des iai californie de
vivre seul plus de trois ans entre 1908
et 1911 dans ces sociétés les individus
sont donc très peu dépendant des autres
et chaque famille peut pratiquement se
débrouiller seul
il ya toujours quelqu'un qui excelle
particulièrement dans un domaine et sur
qui on peut se reposer pour fabriquer
des outils de grande qualité mais on
peut aussi bien son passé chez les
chasseurs cueilleurs il n'y a donc pas
la même conception du travail puisqu'il
est inutile d'acheter on ne produit pas
de richesse ce qui est produit et
consommé instantanément le stock à long
terme est presque impossible et on a
tout à portée de main travailler pour
quoi faire
quoi faire de plus bon mais ne me faites
pas dire ce que je n'ai pas dit les
chasseurs cueilleurs travail il
travaille dans le sens où il recherche
de la nourriture et fabrique des outils
mais en réalité ils travaillent peu très
peu mais on déjà parler à l'occasion
d'un épisode sur la chaîne du vortex
messaline ce dans son ouvrage
judicieusement nommée haches de pierre h
d'abondance a analysé dès les années 70
les temps de travail des chasseurs
cueilleurs étudié par les ethnologues et
ça fait plutôt rêver un individu peut en
quelques heures subvenir aux besoins de
plusieurs autres pour plusieurs jours
chez les coupes du kalahari les adultes
passent en moyenne deux heures et neuf
minutes par jour à travailler ce qui
suffit pour produire 2000 140 calories
par individu enfants compris permettant
même de dégager un excédent pour nourrir
les chiens
ce mode de production est efficace mais
pour rester viable
il suppose une démographie faible les
chasseurs cueilleurs doivent contrôler
drastiquement leur population en se
débarrassant des plus faibles être
agriculteur peut dès lors présenter des
avantages comme celui de ne pas tuer les
vieux dès qu'ils ont du mal à marcher
mais cela veut aussi dire bossé trois
fois plus jean-claude pour faire et 8 ha
ils attaquent au mois de décembre est
finie one mars il y à tous les joueurs
de ils font que ce soit huit heures par
jour pour autant bon nombre de sociétés
agricoles n'ont pas sombré immédiatement
dans un labeur épuisant et infini
salines se distingue notre mode de
production industrielle du mode de
production domestique qui prévaut par
exemple en nouvelle guinée
on y travaille plus certes mais dans la
mesure où il s'agit d'une production de
subsistance
inutile de dégager d'énormes excédents
les terres ne sont pas exploités à leur
maximum
la main d'oeuvre est sous-exploité la
société fonctionne en sous-production
c'est la règle de chaillot nov
l'intensité du travail est inversement
proportionnelle à la capacité de travail
plus nous sommes nombreux à pouvoir
travailler moins chacun d'entre nous a
besoin de le faire ce qui nous
pousserait dès lors à travailler plus
pour gagner plus est un changement de
rapport entre le savoir-faire est
l'outil nous avons perdu du savoir faire
car les outils ont gagné en complexité
ne sommes plus en mesure de tous les
maîtriser
nous devenons dépendants du travail des
autres et de l'argent qui nous permet
d'en acheter le produit
clegg a violé les bons mais dans notre
société le travail ce n'est normalement
pas qu'un facteur d'aliénation beaucoup
de gens la plupart espérons le m leur
profession et travailler leur permet de
s'accomplir socialement et
intellectuellement
normalement on ne peut toutefois
s'empêcher de constater que tous les
emplois ne permettent pas de gagner sa
vie plusieurs personnes que j'ai
rencontrés et interrogés pour préparer
cette vidéo on dit adorer leur travail
mais ne pas parvenir à en vivre
correctement certains excellent dans
leur domaine mais en croit la logique de
l'économie de marché puisque l'offre
qu'il propose ne rencontre pas une
demande suffisante
ils ne sont pas utiles à la société le
domaine de la culture et de la création
général souffre particulièrement de
cette vision pourtant tous ces gens tout
comme les demandeurs d'emploi ils
veulent travailler non
alors comment leur attribuer une part de
la production nos habitudes
contrairement aux chasseurs cueilleurs
nous pousse à associer le travail et la
richesse produite
l'activité ne vaut que pour ceux qu'elle
permet d'acheter valorisant ainsi plus
un trader qu'une aide soignante
cette conception poussé à l'extrême et
bien sûr largement critiquée dans notre
société mais se heurte à de nombreuses
résistances dont ce slogan biblique
si quelqu'un ne veut pas travailler
qu'ils ne mangent pas non plus hérité de
nos révolution agricole et industriel
difficile de proposer une solution ou
même une perspective dans un domaine
aussi politique que le travail soit on
décide de prendre parti soit on a l'air
naïf des propositions existent depuis
longtemps certaines émergent de nos
jours notamment en s'interrogeant sur le
rôle de l'intelligence artificielle qui
pourrait remplacer de nombreux
travailleurs et remettre en question la
daj alors fin du travail revenu
universel et c'est tout le monde obtient
le minimum vital ce qu'ils demandent
déjà être définies pourquoi travaillerai
ton pour accumuler davantage
on passerait en somme due faut-il
travailler pour vivre au vit-on pour
travailler une petite révolution
[Musique]